hey what's up party people we are live
talking about the Transformers the movie
1986. uh I'm supposed to J Gilbert that
is lon Harris We'll be talking about our
deepest thoughts about this really chewy
film there's a lot there's a lot to chew
on there so much going on so much
happening um and then we will tell you
uh uh we're gonna watch it together
we'll show you some deleted scenes we'll
do some q a so put any of your uh
deepest darkest questions about Energon
not which Transformer is which though
please don't ask us which one of them
that's the one with a beak okay I've got
you that far once they say their name
out loud it makes sense like oh sound
wave boomboxed up but if you line them
up this is not to be offensive but if
you line up all the Transformers I
couldn't pick a single one of them out
yeah offended deeply offended the
generation one Transformer fans that's
it Optimus Prime's the big truck
um and then we'll uh tease you with next
week's episode so yeah let's Dive Right
In um granted I did say I did I was
dismissive of the individual properties
of each Transformer right off the bat
but this movie does rock this movie's
great this is more I feel
so many of the other Transformers movies
you get like the you get a little you
get a little Spritz of what you want and
then it's like an hour of Shia LaBeouf
acting like he's on a bunch of blow and
like Josh do you remember watching the
cartoon growing up where it was like
well we don't really have the budget to
make them move or fight outside of a few
insert shots where they turn into
something or throw a punch at the end
this was like all climax yes all the
climax of every cartoon strung together
just like the robots gotta fight and
let's go to fight robots gotta fight and
like this is just wall-to-wall just
robots shooting lasers at other robots
and like violently blowing each other
away and like I think that yeah it's
it's the good stuff that's and it really
helps that they're all robots and I hope
that there's not some one of those robot
android cyborg psychos in the comments
right now they're all robots they say it
it says it in the thing they're robots
they're robots in Disguise it's right
there yeah so it helps that they're all
robots because that gives them license
to in a children's movie just make them
kick the [__] out of each other yeah
just absolutely fight whereas you know
Ninja Turtles had to pull their punches
they had to you know Michelangelo's
swinging Links of salami around in a
foot soldier we are watching I won't
give away what we're watching for next
week but next week we're watching
something that's a lot of action that
was made for television and it really
suffers from that like the A-Team thing
where they've got to shoot the boxes
that are above the bad guys so that the
stuff topples onto the bad guys because
you can't you can't shoot something
shoot a person on television but in
Transformers you could just rip their
heads off yeah fascinating that this was
um I guess this was just a time before
parents noticed or cared because this is
just non-stop violence and War from
start to finish but it's cartoons and so
it's it's so it's fine it's not seen as
like bloody or gruesome so I don't think
anybody because it's fascinating that
that is sort of I've been re-watching
some of the Michael Bay's uh just in the
background
and in three the the final fight between
Optimus Prime and Megatron is so brutal
you're like hey like axes him in the
head and then uses the ax to pull
Megatron's head off and like that would
be like x-rated
you know in his defense is keeping true
to the spirit of Transformers because
you can't tell any of them apart and
they're actually really really hurting
each other right yeah yeah the good
stuff he did it I just don't like their
squishy faces in his movies that really
bothers me tendrils it's too organic and
like they're they're robot they should
their robots from space they're alive
robots but they're still robots and I
feel like he tries to make them too much
like real organic but too far in the
organic Department more he should have
gone more towards a Camaro or like an
IROC Z you know or boxy and and the
other the other while we're on it the
major complaint I have about the
live-action Michael Bay ones as opposed
to this is why did they drop the
transforming sound effect that's such a
trademark thing yeah when they play it
and when they play it in this movie
you're like hell yeah that's the sound
of a robot transforming I know exactly
what that is and they just like not
using it in the movie seems like such a
waste to me somebody might know what's
the what's the deal between the um uh
the like the Foley artist who created
that sound yeah like someone let us know
what that's very distinctive
transforming sound that I'm sure fans
and as soon as I said that were like
you're hearing it in your head it's
never been the sound effect for any
yeah no other that sound doesn't exist
in nature it's not there's no like bird
that sounds like that that's exclusively
a Transformer
oh
restarting
waiting for restarts
so our sound's out of sync well this has
actually been dubbed over from English
we were initially speaking Japanese and
then we hired ourselves to come in and
do Bozo did the dub
uh
we totally off the air right now
all right
look oh wait back to English fun
um as far as that that's as much
Japanese as we know yeah let's just get
into
all right Let's do let's just get into
the trailer uh let's watch together in
sync you and me the Transformers the
movie 1986. Treasure of the Lost lamp
[Music]
you're so burned out after 10 years of
Transformers bayham she's a miner we'll
protect the mother Romeo and Juliet laws
statue two seven zero seven eight
there's three that's crazy that you kind
of skip the only good one but before
Paramount resorts to bestiality return
to fulfilled
it's such a crazy scene
there's so many strange things going on
at once we're supposed to talk about the
Romeo and Juliet law sequence from uh
age of Extinction yeah
he's Irish
yes inexplicably Irish and he's bragging
to Mark Wahlberg like I'm actually a
rally driver for nothing totally wrong
accent he's an Irish guy yeah
hi I'm really driving I'm sponsored
better headboard I want to work on my
fiddle music you're not my friend
anymore oh no we're getting Scottish
yeah they don't like that yeah they
don't
um so yeah he so that's insane already
that like you have this Irish guy
talking about being a rally car driver
for Red Bull in Texas yeah
um so Mark Wahlberg is understandably
confused sometimes he just looks
confused this time I bought it and then
his daughter has been his co-pilot yeah
in the rally car she's his Navigator and
he doesn't know any of this uh bad dad
right I mean you you would think you
would have heard something and then he
pulls out the laminated card that says
he can he's allowed to have he's allowed
to have sex with a 17 year old girl yeah
yeah a card he uses so much like you do
yeah in his wallet that was actually
Michael Bay's card he just lent the
actor
let's get back to the 80s movie
Return to a film so 80s two different
robots turn into boom boxes oh yeah and
they're cassette tapes fight each other
there it is
audacious the Transformers the movie
buckle up for a film that feels like
Game of Thrones but for cartoon robots
that turn into things
as two opposing sides of murder Bots
murder the [__] out of each other for 90
minutes great that doesn't even pause to
mourn the deaths of long-running
characters until they force children to
watch the live slowly drain from Optimus
Prime's body because the only thing more
ruthless than this script is the
Shameless corporate breed that inspired
it the reality is at the time it was a
toy show we just thought we were killing
off the old product line introducing the
new products
the audacity
and total disconnect between Their
audience and uh and the team behind it
I'd be like we just murdered Optimus
Prime he dies in the first 10 minutes
but then they get a new toy so like
you're happy right kid yeah they yeah
it's just it's such an interesting like
like failure to understand how kids play
with toys which is their whole job like
if you're you're a toy maker and how
you're not thinking about like well kids
are gonna be upset if you kill their
favorite toy they're not that's not and
they had the right idea with Megatron
where it's like okay he gets a new suit
of armor so they have to right
it's it's obviously like update the toy
like like here's the version two ver the
new you know he's got to get new armor
and weapons and but you know Murder them
all on screen and it's so brutal it's
like they don't even get to like they're
not they don't die heroic deaths they
just get gunned down and I'll say this
place made for a much better film
horribly misguided decision made for a
better movie well now now going back
it's very exciting and there's nobody
has plot armor normally you'd be like
well Optimus Prime he'll have to come
back at the end no that's the thing dead
permanently you do hold out hope that at
the very end Optimus Prime will be re
resurrected or reborn or something like
that but no I I also went uh I didn't
end up getting any jokes out of it but
you a lot of the like 2B and all of
those free services have the full
classic Transformers cartoon so I went
and watched like the few episodes that
go chronologically after the movie and
they are so like Rodimus Prime is like
well I guess we back uh Cybertron uh
should restart Society like even even
the show feels like they don't know what
to do like everybody's dead and like we
won like uh so I guess uh we should do
some research build a new post office
to a griddle
check this out
but they're on Cybertron there really is
no need to you're not transforming to
disguise yourself yeah there's no humans
was the lore that like we got our
designs for trucks from them no I think
it's that they they come to a new planet
and then they scan whatever the tech is
there and then they learn how to turn
into it so they can like hide out I
think noted I'm sure there's fans
watching like but then exactly going off
the bay continuity you know they've been
around since the time Merlin right
Michael Bay added that that they've been
like watching over Human Society this
whole time but I don't think that's the
turning into like a a mill it turned
into like yeah he also introduces the
wikians which we'll get into here but
like I think that was a new bay wrinkle
as well all right keep going yeah
you're used to a world where
Transformers movies are 90 Josh dumel 10
fighting robots now watch them flip that
ratio for better or worse
[Music]
in this Timeless Adventure about a new
generation of Autobots tasked to save
Cybertron and wow it does not go well
for them
a planet eating God that's part Galactus
and part Mega made from Spaceballs he's
voiced by Cinema Legend Orson Wells or
at least the dying wheezes of Cinema
Legend Orson Welles buried under layers
of sin
in a performance he couldn't have cared
less about if it were a Paul Mason wine
commercial action please
champagne has always been celebrated for
its Excellence its Excellence
so yeah this role killed Orson Welles um
it was already I mean yeah I think a lot
also heavy drinking final role of
Scatman Crothers he died like a month
later after this
um and yeah there was I was watching
some behind the scenes stuff and they
were hard living also respond partly
responsible for Roxanne Wells not just
the Transformers
um he the the
um I don't remember it must have been
the directors talking about how he came
in and did his part and uh he it was
completely unusable they they were just
like this is this does not sound like a
living planet and they had 12 different
synthesizers that they were running his
voice to get up to that point I mean it
was he was it was like an Infamous sort
of thing at the end of his career where
he would take these like voice over
roles and show up you know so what else
has he done well there there's uh there
was the frozen food the birds
they make fun of that on the critic but
that was based on a real thing where he
objected to the ad copy they wanted it
to read and so he was like there's audio
of him yelling at the sound engineer but
I think there were a few more of these
kinds of incidents too it was just like
you know he was a cantankerous guy at
the end of his life and he was a little
bitter that he'd never gotten to finish
like a lot of his films and never got to
sort of be uh continue his film
directing career and uh you know you
know what I did this morning I played
the voice of a toy some terrible robot
toy from Japan that changed from one
thing to another yeah this should have
been our uh our title
I play a planet I Menace somebody called
something or other then I'm destroyed
there you go yeah that is that sums it
up yeah he was basically long in the
short of it he's great
um but now with AI we can make him be
over there
we could trap his soul
it would sound real the same like or is
it whether if you actually trapped his
soul inside of a planet
oh God oh my God I'm gonna kill you
are you ready to rock because this movie
has the best 80s music since Rocky IV
featuring the composer who scored Rocky
4 with enough hair metal jammed into
every second to kick off a combiner's
worth of 80 satanic Panic featuring hits
like Stan Bush's power Rock ballad the
Touch You Got The Touch
Stan Bush's power-up battle the touch
again
and Stan Bush's power rug Ballad The
Touch one more time for good measure
a Rock ballad so powerful Stan Bush
wrote it for Sylvester Stallone's Cobra
and is probably why Mark Wahlberg joined
the franchise down the line You Got The
Touch
We Salute You Mr Bush
yeah just stand bush has got to be of
like the survivors the um that era of of
stuff he's my favorite I think wow I
think he's number one probably number
one there's another guy I'm blanking on
his name he does the uh like the rad
soundtrack among others I know bay also
in in ambulance he he brought back that
uh Christopher Cross Classic sailing oh
that's great which is a similar era a
similar kind of sound John Farnham I
also love oh John Farnham sure but I do
think that um dare is probably my
favorite song off this soundtrack more
so than the than the touch
not Weird Al dare to be stupid
I love Weird Al I thought that was a
strange Choice it's a very strange
Choice it's probably the only action
scene in cinema history that's set to a
Weird Al song that I can think of that
choice to to make a profoundly stupid
scene from a movie scored but I dare to
be stupid is this meta commentary or is
it just like this is funny I I think
it's just literally like that the the
it's got a really like aggressive
fast-paced driving sound and they're
like this robots could fight over this
that's that's the mark of a good song
yeah it's like I could I could Envision
robots fighting while this plays in the
background therefore put Taylor Swift no
yeah can't imagine robots fighting over
it not
all right keep going
first franchises that take forever to
get to the fan favorite cash hits I mean
characters well scrap in as Hasbro
desperately tries to hold the attention
of an eight-year-old audience all hopped
up on New Coke I'm trying to get them
into the shuttle Ultra Magnus because I
know he can't watch the shuttle until I
get into the shuttle but I can't seem to
get them into the shadow because they're
impossible impossible from the inside my
cause
to the Dinobots Dinobots
to the Constructor cards
the shark decons
the quintessons and their cruel Masters
the greatest songs to a living version
of the junkyard where all of these toys
live now
cool let them all no seriously by law
we're not allowed to finish the trailer
until you go buy a toy after the film is
done killing childhoods
they were scared for some reason that
this would get a g rating well that I we
found that on the internet I don't know
it's not true it was in the behind the
scenes oh okay well there you go because
I did see people saying that online but
I didn't say that that is why they
dropped that in there is they were
concerned that a g rating would be death
in theaters kids teenage boys would want
to go see a Jeep they would associate
that with like Disney cartoons or
whatever it wasn't behind the scenes it
was a Comic-Con appearance from the
writers okay I watched and he talks
about how they just had the guy say [__]
just for no reason
um yeah it's just one and I think there
there was like at the time I remember
people were debating like does he say he
might say shoot I think that she said
shoot it's like it's very clearly that
he says [__] but you have so much murder
in this film were you really concerned
you see the smoke come out of their dead
mouth
um Optimus Prime's dying words this was
nice they get a lot of mileage out of
the fact that they're not they're not
human so like you could show their
bodies being ripped apart it's not
violent but I guess well that
ad almost gets boiled in acid right in
front of them oh well yeah spike is a
terrible dad and uh poor Daniel has been
abandoned with robot like is that just
left him like left the planet where's
mom left him in the care of these robots
and like are you sure you trust these
alien robots do you know what's best for
your human boy also PG-13 couldn't have
been a PG that rating system must have
been shaken up because it was a temple
of doom right which right that come out
yeah or no I mean that was before this
yeah what I believe PG-13 existed at
this point but this movie was not maybe
they were just confused
um because now I feel like you put one
you put curses in there to get to a
PG-13
right although I don't the standards
have changed because I remember
Spaceballs was PG and that has an F-bomb
in it oh interesting Rick Moranis says
even in the future nothing works yeah
like I remember that I remember that
specifically because as a kid I think
that was one of the first f-bombs I'd
heard in a movie it was like oh my God
that is a that is
that should be a 13 and up movie Just
because you don't you don't get half the
jokes granted I watched it from
preschool on yeah adult themes I guess
are what you'd call it but it's very
like just sexual so funny what you miss
yeah you just don't pick up on it but
there's not like nudity in it or like I
was rewatching Ace Ventura that I
watched a million times yeah there's an
early scene and I finally understand
what's happening when he's holding the
ceiling fan you hear the you hear his
pants unzip yeah there's a child you're
like I thought she was just spinning him
around real fast it was fun yeah yeah
now you know all right keep going
placement Bots like Ultra Magnus another
big truck but without the nuts cup and
hot rod just bought it I can't deal with
that now a cocaine
what about me RC the only female
Transformer who raises all the same
uncomfortable questions posed by the
existence of Smurfette wheelie a weird
rhyming homeschooled kid
Judd Nelson's hot rod who's not the
stepdad but the dad who stepped up
fisher jumping today hi Dano Daniel
widwicky a child both adopted and
abandoned by the Autobots
I forgot that that was a mythical
bloodline by the end of these things
well I think I think that's a bae thing
in the in the in the the classic 80s
cartoon it's just a father and son and
their name is wit Wiki yeah and then Bae
was like oh I'm gonna make that the name
of Shia LaBeouf's character as kind of
continuity but then by the end of the
Bay movies yeah he's introduced like
throughout history humans have helped
out the Transformers that are all part
of like an elite secret club called the
wikians which doesn't make a lot of
sense and then the timelines don't
exactly match up because as we know this
movie takes place in the year 2005. the
shocking future year of 2005.
I would never set some how far in the
future would you have to go before you
were like setting a full sci-fi story
with Interstellar traffic got to figure
hundreds hundreds hundreds of years
there's no way in 1986 I'm calling what
20 years yeah they were like like 20
years from now we'll be sending traffic
back and forth to Cybertron all the time
I mean that's obvious 100 years absolute
minimum probably 200. I mean I guess the
idea would be once you've broken the
seal you know like once first Contact is
made then the aliens are just like well
here's everything you need to come fly
to space all the time and then it's uh
then it's game on you know it's like in
the MCU it's still in MCU time it's what
a decade after like Iron Man and like
how different is the world like once
they once you jump into being a comic
book world it's all over that's a good
point yeah they've been through a lot oh
my God half of them disappeared there's
a dead Eternal poking out of the Arctic
and they didn't even haven't even gotten
around to it yet
Asgard selling Thanos ice cream that
doesn't make anything it doesn't make
sense
[Music]
so return to the
2005 it is the year 2005. for a toy
commercial that has no right to kick as
much as it does I got better things to
do tonight
that may be kind of light on your actual
favorite Transformers soon I shall be
one with the Matrix but hey look it's
Astro train he turns into a train that's
also a rocket that's pretty cool right I
mean you never know when you're gonna
need a old-timey space train who's also
a rocket why don't we kill this guy off
again
absolutely recognizes he's the best one
coming soon to the Transformers oh thank
Primus
starring
dogs like a truck truck a truck we have
Optimus Prime at home I think the mcgun
now orbit Wells unsolved matrices is
that Canon I'm the scat man
G is for Grimlock they're good enough
for me ancient aliens that are also
robots the storyline
energobots have cursed my name is Danny
the D is for dingus King for a Day and
okay the cool care is made a guy with a
sword is right there and he's not
getting the Matrix
the assassination of Optimus Prime by
the coward Hasbro
hey if you thought this movie was too
much for kids wait until breast force
and Headmaster show up Transformers can
be weird man
it sure can so let's just say we
consulted with some Transformers fans on
this one who had some things to say
about uh breast force and uh and that
one at the end yeah who should have
inherited The Matrix and stuff like that
you know so you got you got to consult
access yeah I I was when I was like
eight years old I was like a pretty I
was very into this this was a franchise
I was that was very important to me as a
kid I just like I forget like I go even
going back to this movie which I know I
saw in theaters and a bunch of times
like I didn't really remember a lot of
people just get old yeah see all of my
favorite things are dead and they died
very early
into like uh Pirates of Dark Water oh
sure fantastic I remember that Samurai
Pizza cats that one certainly lived yeah
right over you know it was a very
obvious uh Japanese Riff on um
oh I think we all got there yeah
yeah I figured that out but I didn't I
don't remember it thank you all for
watching to this point we have more
coming up we're going to answer your
questions we're going to show you um
some deleted scenes uh hit like and hit
subscribe and watch the other videos on
fandom entertainment they're pretty good
that's my pitch
[Applause]
but for now let's watch the outtakes
from the Transformers Australia check it
out
starring
Peter called Ice Road Trucker that's me
Bender no the other one hello fellow
kids I like Bots that were Abercrombie
and Fitch preppy bot legging Tron you're
an idiot Starscream guns don't kill
people people that turn into guns kill
people and also guns ego and also the
voice of a living planet stack party
space lease buckets live long and
process Purple Rain Purple Rain remember
to wax for a great shining Jurassic
spark antique roadshow Bee Movie Bumble
core the full monty Autobot deficit
hyperactivity disorder mandroid damn
Daniel again in the white Exo Suit
Wesley Crusher and bottom gun
Hasbro's cars
one is cyber that was mine so laser b
can turn into a cassette tape and fly
inside sound wave and then sound wave
plays him that's at least five percent
sexual right you have to tone this down
for a PG but it's like oh man like yeah
yeah I just come inside me yeah like
laser being like flying out of him it's
like does that feel good I had a little
relieved
yeah uh I can't wait to be inside you
like it's just like this this shouldn't
be this is getting cyber kind of weird
figure out a way to do it the different
um all right so
um FJ pretzer asks is this a franchise
that works better in animation or could
it work in live action had Bay never
been involved I feel like the good one
was a fluke at this time I don't know I
like bumblebee I like I thought it was
like at least promising that okay
too it has that opening sequence on
Cybertron where it's all robots and it's
awesome and it feels like the yeah I
don't think you can do 90 minutes of
that but you could have that I think you
could I honestly think you could do it
very much like the 80s movie where you
have human characters I'm not saying no
humans at all but you don't have to have
them be the leads I don't think you need
to do Shia LaBeouf as Sam Danny yeah I
think they could be part they're in the
mix but like it it can mostly be a robot
movie like we had we've been an Apes
movie in those that's right like we you
can do it we we just had a blue alien
movie and it's like they're mostly Navy
there's a few humans in there yeah
there's some scenes where spider is the
only person who's jumping around making
an avatar two-level uh dedication to
your craft to make another Transformers
movie saying like James Cameron
Transformers an avatar four one for you
one for us uh MJ Prince also follows up
with that uh he's off on her trip to
London Dublin and Barcelona do you have
any any recommendations for any of those
three cities oh uh I've only been to
London out of those three uh but sure
there's still like I I really enjoyed
the first day I was in London I took a
river boat down the Thames and like they
point out all the stuff stuff and like
that was great because it gives you like
a real layout of the city and like here
are other things I know I want to see
and other things I don't care about and
like it's a good first day in London
thing if you've never been to the city
before and it's just cool to go in a
room you're going to the tower bridge
and it's cool yeah I'll give you a uh oh
it closed permanently oh the pandemic oh
well I also yeah I still never know one
more cool place I went on Fleet Street
there's a pub called Ye Old Cheshire
Cheese that's like it goes back to like
the 1500s and like Dr Johnson used to
drink there and stuff so like that's
cool there's no places in America that
are that old nice yeah nothing's old
here yeah
um I had fun there radar City update
Channel which iconic director should do
a future toy film He suggests Wesley for
example Wes Anderson for My Little Pony
I do think Wes Anderson not that one but
I do think Wes Anderson would be well
suited for a toy commercial just because
he seems a toy movie because he's so
precious about arranging things and
putting them in their little place yeah
I feel like a classic tool like like
mystery date or something like a 50s or
60s toy that would be perfect for that
kind of like Wes Anderson he does seem
kind of Twee enough that he would just
love playing with toys for yeah I mean I
think the the answer to me is you want
Justin Lin you want Vin Diesel collab in
on that street sharks
yeah isn't that what we all know is that
what the people want what the people
want I think we demand the street trucks
and now that Dwayne and Vin are friends
again
perfect perfect team up for the Street
Sharks uh Luis Valenzuela says if you
had to go out in a blaze of glory like
Optimus did what song would you be
blasting what's your blaze of glory song
mine is the touch because I'm basic can
Mundy dare to be stupid
uh no a different I go with a different
Weird Al song
yes yeah you got it I'll go with a
Timber by Pitbull featuring Kesha it's
going down
timber took me a second I was like Tim I
know I know that I recognize that title
also from radar City uh what would be
the worst thing for a robot to transform
into example a bowl of soup that's a
that's a straight up movie fights right
I might have I might have written that
down for movie fights before that feels
exactly that's great yeah and everybody
would always have like a dirty answer oh
vibrating anal baby like nah don't do
that I mean it's bad we'll have to talk
about it for 20 minutes and you're gonna
get tired of talking it'd be a good
speed run
yeah
I think what would be fun is is when
it's like very in the moment technology
that gets outdated very quickly like
Hellraiser 3 it's so fun now that it's
like the the CD player Cena bite and
stuff so I think you really want like a
VR I'm a mini disc player yeah like a VR
headset Transformer no you have to still
record onto me like a cassette it's very
complicated yeah you're gonna hit both
both
the quality is way better it's worth it
trust me
I had to meet us
yeah a Transformer that turns into like
a GoPro so it's just like very tied to
like one specific era and then he's like
uh
I guess I should change what I turn into
nobody has a GoPro anymore
um let's see so there's lots of good
ones I'm James Bond What 80s cartoon do
you want them to bring back
um like Thundercats with the cats CG
that would be that'd be something yeah I
don't know about that yeah one Pirate's
Dark Water back I think there's room for
more than one pirates franchise at a
time and Pirates of the Caribbean
doesn't seem to be doing much so it was
great you had the the monkey Bird that's
that's gonna be horrifying yeah yeah I
uh I mean from the 80s uh you know for
sure I feel like we're we're overdue for
for Masters of the Universe in a
non-like cartoon like we've got those
Netflix cartoons which are pretty good
I'm not complaining but like where's our
we I I'm ready for the big live action
attorney uh film that really gets to do
it because the the 80s one uh you know
they didn't have the budget so it's
mostly just like in Suburbia but Dolph
Lundgren is He-Man
and I think we're the the stage is set
now we have the technology the the
interest level is there to really do it
splashy big the way we have a technology
we could finally realize James Cameron
could finally spend 2 billion realizing
attorney owns
I don't even think it would be that I
really don't think it would even be that
hard like if you could make a Middle
Earth show for Amazon you could put
attorney on the big screen wow because
it has such a proven track record of of
success I mean listen
uh
um and we'll end with this uh uh
D.A barakis why wasn't Joe a part of
this
oh
well
can't can't say can't say saying them
all saying them all right
no Joe does not uh
works for a different company yeah
exactly yeah exactly uh and then finally
uh benzai 10 uh are you guys looking
forward to doing the odds trailer for
the new uh rise of the Beast
Transformers are we gonna act like it
won't exist I think we'll do it I don't
know let me act like it won't exist like
almost all the Transformers we haven't
done Dark Side of the Moon
um oh that's the one I just watched yeah
or bumblebees so we've got those in our
pocket if we need to but yeah I think
we'll we'll probably dip it is is this
one supposed to be good what what are we
here
like solid I feel like it's like I would
expect other people love I think people
are saying better than the Michael Bays
that turned everyone off but is it good
enough to win people back will remains
to be seen so like we're we'll we'll see
but it's the guy who directed Creed 2
which I thought was pretty good I like
that so like you know who who knows
who's to say I check it out it'd be
weird if that got really great reviews
it'd be I think it I think whether we do
it it really depends on whether you all
go see it like if it's a huge hit we'll
definitely do it and if nobody but he
goes to see it we definitely won't do it
and if it's in the middle we'll have to
figure that out we only do huge hits
here like next week's on this trip
okay bad example but you know what I
mean we have to do things if they're
huge like when Super Mario came out
there was no chance we weren't gonna do
it because it was such a huge film yeah
that's awesome well next week's one will
be speeding onto your screen it's based
around we're doing it because it's
obviously Italian of course yeah
um but not this thing we're doing not
this nobody likes this thing we're doing
no one's ever like this me included and
I'm the one watching it
miserable can't wait nightmare I don't
know if that's enough of a clue but it's
probably not but for once we won't give
it away this is the real thing yeah uh
or are we being tricky about what our
clue is for next week
um so there's your Clues uh thank you so
much for joining us we'll see you next
Tuesday right here on Australia
commentaries bye-bye
[Music]
foreign